Music Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO mit mir. Mein Name ist Stefan Thielse und mir gegenüber sitzt Florentin Well. Na ja, was heißt gegenüber sitzen? Es ist im Tiss trennen zu viele schmerzliche Kilometer, die wir heute nicht zusammen sein können. Wir können es nicht in die Augen gucken, sondern wir müssen mit schlecht eingestellten Kamerawinkeln Vorliebe nehmen bei Skype. Ja, das ist wieder so eine Folge. Ihr habt es kommen sehen, ihr wolltet eine normale Folge, ihr wolltet eurer Freundin, eurem Freund heute mal den Podcast-Ufo zeigen. Ja, keine Chance, das ist wieder so eine Folge. So eine Folge, wo man sich reinredet, wo wir beide mit Sophistisch-Stimmen sprechen. Ja, ja, wozu? Wozu war der Lacher?
Für eine letzte Folge war das, hast du das eingespielt gerade mit dem Sampler, den ich nicht sehe, der auf dem Tisch liegt, wo du den Gags vorher eingesprochen hast? Ich schau nebenbei noch gerade was. Ich schau nebenbei noch für Family Guy. Ich glaub, Skype wollte ursprünglich Sky heissen, hat dann bemerkt, dass es Sky schon gibt und dachte sich, ja dann halt Skype mit P dran.
Ja, ich glaube, da ist jemand eher auf Tastatur abgerutscht. Also Sky geschrieben und dann nochmal, hallo, bist du noch da oder war der Witz einherzuschlechen? Ja.
Ich will da eher, apropos schlechte Witze, sehr lustig habe ich letztens angesehen, unglaublich.
Es gibt ja immer für Comedy-Fans so ein paar Ereignisse im Jahr, wo man auch jauchzt. So, Fussballfans haben die Champions League, Fussballfans haben die WM, was haben Comedy-Fans? Ja, die neue Staffel Family Guy, die neue Staffel Simpsons, alles nicht mehr das wahre, aber es gibt ein Comedy-Ereignis im Jahr, das immer die Herzen höher schlägen lässt, und zwar The Roast Off. Der Comedy Central Roast. Es gibt schon ein paar gute, er wird dabei, also da wurden schon Leute geroastet. Justin Bieber war dabei, James Franco, alle geroastet, kann man sich gerne mal reinziehen. Ich habe mal welche zu nennen, die ihr kennt. Ja, kann man sich gerne mal reinziehen an einem Wochenende, wenn man nicht so viel zu tun hat. Und jetzt als letztes wurde geroasted Bruce Willis. Ja, also tolles, tolles Roast-Opfer. Und mit dabei war, und den finde ich ja generell genial, also der tritt ja immer wieder auf, Dennis Rodman. Das ist ja unfassbar, das ist ja so ein ehemaliger Basketballspieler, der sich dann irgendwie durchgeschlängelt hat zu Nordkorea-Korrespondent, einfach der weirde Typ, den man auf die Party einlädt, einfach weil es lustig ist. Und genau diese Rolle spielt er hier auch beim The Roast of Bruce Willis. Und es ist unglaublich lustig. Und ich möchte sogar gerne eine Stelle einspielen. Das machen wir jetzt. Ich glaube nicht, dass es technisch gesehen funktioniert. Ich schicke dir den Link. Aber es war nämlich auch dabei Ed Norton. Der Schauspieler Ed Norton war auch mit dabei. Und weißt du, Roast, es ist ja schwierig. Also man hat ja so den, der Roastee, der geroastet wird. Klar, es gibt so ein paar klischeehafte Sachen. Ha ha ha, du bist Alkoholiker. Ha ha ha, dies und das. Man muss sich halt ein bisschen was überlegen. Man muss fein angreifen, man muss aber auch wortgewandt angreifen. Gerade wenn man so der fünfte von sieben ist, dann muss schon was dabei sein. Also da muss man sich dann schon... Are you all right? No, you are all or left. Das kommt dann... Das Video wurde mir jetzt wieder in meiner Timeline gespielt und es ist immer noch das lustigste Video, was es auf YouTube gibt. Muss man sagen, bei America's Got Talent kommt eine Person auf die Bühne, die sagt, dass sie schon mal bei einer Comedy School, auf einer Comedy School war. Und dann fängt sie an mit der Comedy und sagt, are you all right? No, you are all or left. Und das haben wir, glaube ich, schon mal erzählt. Ja, war wirklich... Eine große Stille und dann kommen die ganzen Dirts von den ganzen No. Was so wunderschön ist, weil es auf keiner Ebene einen Sinn ergibt. Sie sind nicht alle links, der Raum ist ausgeglichen, ausgestattet. Es ergibt keinen Sinn. Wahrscheinlich hat sie sich den Gag überlegt, bevor sie den Raum gesehen hat, dachte sich, fuck, die sitzen ja gar nicht alle auf der linken Seite. Ja, wie, vielleicht liessen Afrika immer alle auf der linken Seite. Das ist immer so, wenn man sich so Gags für ganz spezielle Szenarien überlegt. Man hat acht Gags, falls jemandem irgendwie die Krücke umfällt im Publikum. Und es ist einfach nie mit Krücke da. Ich habe den Link geschickt. Ja, ich muss kurz die Werbung gucken. Ich muss kurz die Werbung gucken für FIFA. Also bei Roast geht es ja darum, nicht einfach nur draufzuhauen, sondern auch wirklich wortgewandt sich was zu überlegen.
Und wir gucken mal ganz kurz rein, wie Dennis Rodman das macht, und er macht hier einen Gag zu seinem Co-Roaster, Ed Norton.
Ed Norton, und die Feedline ist, du nennst dich jetzt nicht mehr Ed Norton, sondern Edward Norton. Schau mal rein. Hey, Ed Norton, wassup, man? Edward goes by Edward, and not Ed, because he is a real dick.
Das ist der Gag.
Was? Ich muss es mir noch machen.
Und wunderschön auch die Reaktion von Edward Norton, direkt danach.
What? Hey, Ed Norton, what's up, man? Edward goes by Edward and not Ed, because he is a real dick. Aber das wäre auch meine Reaktion. Das ist so, das habe ich auch mit Leuten, die ich nicht connecte. Ja. So Taxifahrer oder sowas, wenn die einen Gag machen, man will höflich sein. Du kannst jetzt nicht sagen, was, was haben sie gerade gemeint? Man hat ja gelernt, dass es dann, man muss ja lachen. Die Gesellschaft verlangt ja dann von allem, dass man so sozial dann doch ist. Ja, gerade wenn es ist. Man will ja auch immer so ein Goodsport sein und sagen, ha ha, man dachte über die Gags überein. Aber ich finde es so lustig, weil ich finde, das ist die lustigste Reaktion, die man haben kann, dieses resignierende Hände hochschwerfen und einfach so mit zusammengezogenem Gesicht die Kopfschütteln so. Was zur Hölle war das denn? Aber man weiss auch nicht, ob's bewusst ein weirder Gag war oder ob der Typ einfach merkwürdig ist. Unglaublich. Aber anders, man weiss es nicht genau, macht auch auf keiner Ebene Sinn. Überhaupt nicht. Und tatsächlich gibt es ja auch diesen Roast von Donald Trump. Oh ja. Wo, ich glaube, oder war das das Correspondents Dinner? Auf jeden Fall hat Seth Meyers Donald Trump fertig gemacht und dann sieht man halt auch immer seine Reaktionen, aber anders als Ed Norton, der ja noch sportlich mit diesem schlechten Gag umgeht, zeigt Donald Trump ganz offen seinen Hass immer. Und er ist halt immer sauer. Und immer saurer auch. Und ich frage mich, wie lustig es wäre, wenn irgendwann die Kamera umschwenkt und der Platz ist einfach leer. Und dann schwenkt die Kamera wieder und dann wird wieder zurückgeschnitten zu dem Pult und dann steht ja Donald Trump, der den einfach hat weggeschickt lassen und der dann selber anfängt zu sprechen. Oder haut er auch immer auf die Fresse dem Redner. Ich finde das sehr lustig. Es ist wirklich Das ist wirklich grossartig. Was hat Donald Trump, der den einfach hat weggeschickt lassen und der dann selber anfängt zu sprechen oder so. Oder haut er auch immer auf die Fresse dem Redner. Ich finde das sehr lustig. Es ist wirklich grossartig. Ich meine, was hat Donald Trump erwartet, was da passiert? Jemand wie Donald Trump kann man davon ausgehen, dass er denkt, die werden jetzt alle loben, weil er so krass ist. Aber es ist schon, ich mag diese Rose-Kultur, es ist einfach immer gut, weil man hat auch das Gefühl, da sind Leute, die haben Spaß auf der Bühne und haben Bock und können mal Sachen sagen, die man sonst vielleicht sich nicht sagt. Ich kann ja mal einen kleinen Einwurf machen aus einer kleinen Geschichte aus der guten Arbeit Originals Zeit. Und zwar wollten wir auch immer einen Roast machen. Wir wollten irgendwie so einen Roast als Sketch machen. Und wir wollten immer machen The Comedy Central Roast of Schnecke. Und wir wollten eine Schnecke roasten, wir wollten Tiere roasten. Im jeden Fall so süße Tiere wie Pandas oder so. Ja, und dann sitzt da so ein süsser Panda, auf dem man immer schneiden kann, nach einem besonders harten Witz, der brutal unter die Gürtellinie ging. Und dann siehst du diesen Panda, wie er so in einem Bambusstock nagt. Ey, aber ohne Scheiß, können wir das nicht bei Rocket Beans machen? The Roast of Schnecken? The Roast of Tiere, The Animal Roast. Ja, dann kriegt man ein Panda-Bär in Rocket Beans Studio. ist nicht so leicht, glaube ich. In Hamburg, Weltstadt, in Hamburg wird auch alles durchgeschleust. Am Hamburger Hafen, hallo? Wir werden doch illegale Hamster und Pandas geschleust. Das ist doch kein Step, oder nicht? Ja, stimmt schon. Stimmt hin. Wir haben uns vor ein paar Wochen auch schon mal gefragt, wo du von deinen Urlaubstorys erzählt hast, vor wem man wirklich man selbst ist. Und ich habe jetzt herausgefunden, ich habe nicht herausgefunden, vor wem oder in welchen
Situationen ich wirklich ich selbst bin, aber ich habe herausgefunden, in welchen Situationen
ich am meisten davon entfernt bin.
Okay.
Und zwar Taxifahrer, bei Taxifahrern.
Ja, ja.
Das ist meine Erkenntnis, weil man will ein Gespräch am Laufen halten und vor allem,
wenn man auf einer Party war und vielleicht was getrunken hat oder sowas, ich kann es nicht ertragen, im Taxi zu sitzen und ich kann die Stille nicht ertragen. Es ist vor allem, es ist auch nicht wie bei Uber oder sowas, wo man zumindest das Gefühl hat, der Fahrer will ihm gerade einen Gefallen tun, weil er ich glaube, man kann bei Uber sogar anklicken, dass man nicht reden will. Das, was mega geil ist. Oder du kannst halt zumindest sagen, ich möchte gerade nicht reden und der der Taxifahrer lässt es dann oder der Oberfahrer, weil er keine schlechte Bewertung bekommen will. Aber beim Taxifahrer hast du diese Augenhöhe, diese unerträgliche Augenhöhe. Das heißt, du musst die ganze Zeit versuchen, das Gespräch am Laufen zu halten. Und ich habe damit totale Probleme. Und ich bin selten so nervös wie im Taxi, weil ich die ganze Zeit rattert ist. Ich suche die ganze Zeit nach Themen. Und oft sind das Menschen, die haben nichts mit meiner Lebensrealität zu tun. Die sind ganz weit woanders, die haben für ein anderes Leben. Und dann habe ich nur gemerkt, dass er sich aufgeregt hat, dass die Ampel so rot war. Und ich war so glücklich über diesen Impuls, dass ich angefangen habe mit ihm, und er hat sich dann so gesteigert, weil ich habe gemerkt, das ist genau sein Thema. Das kann man sich vorstellen, dass Ampeln das Thema für einen Taxifahrer sind. Da hat man auf jeden Fall grünes Licht. Ja, wow. Da habe ich jedenfalls gesehen, dass er sich aufregt. Ja, in Köln sind die Ampeln echt schlimm eingestellt, oder? Keine Ahnung von Ampeln. Ja, weil ich meine, wir sind hier alleine an der Kreuzung, oder? Und es kommt kein Auto und wir haben trotzdem Rot. Ich meine, da gibt es noch so Anforderungsampeln oder so. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, und dann habe ich gemerkt, das ist genau sein Thema, dann hat er gesagt, ja, oder in anderen Städten gibt es da einfach sehr viel Kreisverkehr und ich so, ja, natürlich, Kreisverkehre, warum gibt es nicht mehr Kreisverkehre? Und dann hat sich so hochgesteigert dieses Gespräch und irgendwann wurde es so The Roast of Köln, of the Kölns Ampeln, aber ich habe gemerkt, es ist mir eigentlich so scheißegal im echten Leben.
Der echte Stefan interessiert sich dafür kein bisschen, aber ich hab dann gemerkt, wie ich mich da reingesteigert habe plötzlich und sauer war, auch wirklich sauer war irgendwann auf die Ampeln in Köln, weil ich einfach gemerkt, dass es ein Thema ist. Ich glaube auch, dass dieser Modus dieses Nach-Themen-Suchen
ist eigentlich schon der beste Indikator dafür, dass es grad nix ist.
Du willst nicht mit Leuten Kontakt haben, mit denen du in solchen Situationen bist, wo du denkst,
was sag ich jetzt als nächstes, was könnte ich noch sagen, so dieses Rattern. Ich glaube, das ist ein schlechtes Zeichen. Das habe ich aber immer, das habe ich in acht, das habe ich in neunzig Prozent. Wirklich, mit jedem? Ja, ich nehme immer, lass keine Stille entstehen. Ich war heute beim Friseur zum Beispiel und da bin ich so froh, dass du dieses Go-To-Thema Frisur hast. Im Taxi hast du das nicht. Im Taxi hast du nicht, kannst du nicht sagen, ja, Taxis. Wie lange haben sie heute noch? Das ist meine erste Frage. Aber beim Friseur soll ich mal vielleicht irgendwann mal hinten ein bisschen kürzer, also diese Floskel, die du einbringen kannst, damit das Gespräch anlaufen ist. Aber hast du das nicht? Ich dachte, wir wären da sehr ähnlich. Nee, aber ich habe eine andere Strategie.
Bei mir geht es immer darum, möglichst schnell klarzumachen,
dass ich kein Wort reden möchte.
Auch bei Taxi fahren wirklich immer Kopfhörer auf.
Ich glaube, das ist mein Vorteil,
dass ich immer diese Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer aufhabe, generell.
Im Taxi?
Im Taxi habe ich, natürlich, im Taxi habe ich die auf.
Und dann sagt er so etwas wie, wo fahren sie hin und ich so nur,
einfach um wirklich direkt, also ich glaube, das ist wirklich das magische Zauber dieses damit kannst du wirklich jeden zerstören jeden Gesprächswillen zerstören diese aufgerissenen Augen und dieses Deuten auf die Kopfhörer dieses ich verstehe sie gerade genau ja diese ich verstehe sie gerade nicht Geste und dann kommt oft noch der Blick in den Rückspiegel oder nachdem und auf Beifahrersitz... Gute Frage, Beifahrersitz oder Rücksitz? Ja, immer Rücksitz natürlich. Aber allein das schaffe ich nicht sozial. Klar. Da denke ich mir, ich habe das vor allem mal, ich habe ein paar Freunde nach Hause gebracht abends nach einer Party. Und dann war halt zuerst die Person weg hinten rechts, dann war die Person weg vorne rechts. Ja. Und dann habe ich aber den Moment verpasst, dass ich gesagt habe, willst du dich nicht nach vorne setzen?
Heißt, ich habe dann einen Freund nach Hause gefahren, der hinten im Wagen saß, und du hast direkt dieses Taxifahrer. Direkt geht so der Griff auch aufs Taxometer, um also die Kosten zu starten, den Zähler zu starten, aber das ist einfach ein ruhiges Gefühl, du kannst das Gespräch nicht zurückführen, aber das ist eine interessante Sache. Nee, das Beste, was du haben kannst, sind Kopfhörer, weil die Logik hilft dir. Wenn der dich anspricht und du nimmst den Kopfhörer ab mit diesem, wie bitte, was haben sie gerade gesagt, so und dann sprichst du und dann setzt du die Kopfhörer wieder auf, dann hast du die Logik etabliert, Kopfhörer an, ich höre nichts, wenn ich mit dir reden will, muss ich sie abnehmen, ergo, wenn ich sie jetzt wieder aufhab, kannst du nicht mit mir kommunizieren. Und dann ist ganz klar, dann verstehen die meistens auch, dass du nichts damit zu tun haben willst. Oder einfach no comprendo, oder einfach dieses, das ist auch gut, einfach dieses, äh. Aber wusstest du, dass man als Uber, wenn man Uber fährt in den USA, aber ich glaube, ich bin die meiste Zeit gefahren, du bist nicht die gefahren, oder hast du auch mal mit Uber gefahren, weil ich habe irgendwann gemerkt, dass man selber auch bewertet wird.
Als Gast?
Ja, als Gast. Du gibst nicht nur Sterne, du kriegst auch Sterne. Und ich habe nur ein Rating von 4,78. Das heißt, irgendwer hat mich schlechter bewertet als fünf. Aber ich habe immer versucht, mit denen zu reden und immer so Amerika gelobt. Und ich weiß nicht, woran es lag. Ich glaube, es war der, der uns zum Yankee Stadium gefahren hat. Ah ja, ja, ja. Weil der ist ein bisschen schnell gefahren und wir waren alle so ein bisschen nervös und haben dann auch teilweise geschrien und so, um an diesen Panikgriffen festhalten. Das war, glaube ich, ein Problem.
Das hat ihm nicht gefallen. Nee, rückblickend waren mir da schlechte Gäste. Da muss man einfach auch ertragen, dass man gerade in Lebensgefahr lebt. Glaubst du, diese Bewertung nimmt irgendwann überhand? Es gibt ja so in China dieses ganze System, mit die Bürger werden bewertet und dann kriegt man irgendwie billigere Tickets, wenn man ein guter Bürger ist und so was. Und was ja auch durch diese Informationszeitalter
total gut möglich ist, dass du einfach alles bewertest.
Ich glaube, da gab es auch mal so eine App,
wo man einfach alles bewerten kann,
wo du dann deine Freunde bewerten kannst,
wo du dann ein Haus bewerten kannst, alles.
Und der dann einfach immer überall deine Wertung registriert.
Und glaubst du, dass so das nächste Zeitalter,
so dieses Fünf-Sterne-Zeitalter,
dass einfach alles bewertet wird
und auch so was wie Geld oder so was gar nicht mehr so eine grosse Rolle spielt, sondern eher die Bewertungen, sondern dass man wirklich auch das einfach als Umsatz dann sozusagen hat, als Währung, einfach diese gute Bewertung. Dass du einfach nicht reich bist, sondern du hast eine hohe Bewertung und dadurch wirkt deine Bewertung wieder mehr. Gibt es ja auch eine Black Mirror-Folge dazu. Das ist so, glaube ich, der nächste Schritt. Wir hatten erst Geld, jetzt momentan haben wir Daten und als nächstes kommen Bewertungen als höchstes Gut. Was ich daran toll finde, dass die Menschen am meisten Macht haben, die am besten bewertet wurden. Das ist das Gute. Dass gute Menschen sind an der Macht. Das ist das Beste daran. Das ist einfach eine gute Idee. Wann kommt der Moment, wo zwei und vier Sterne Bewertungen abgeschafft werden? Weil das Internet neigt ja auch zu extremen. Und ich finde, also ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben, glaube ich, zwei Sterne für etwas gegeben, zum Beispiel bei Amazon oder so oder vier Sterne. Ja, das stimmt. Ich glaube, du brauchst die, ich glaube, du brauchst die aber, um Durchschnitt zu berechnen. Ich glaube, du kannst bei Amazon, natürlich gibst du meistens 5,1 oder irgendwas anderes,
aber ich glaube, du kannst so gut einen Durchschnitt darstellen.
Wenn du weisst, ah, Durchschnitt, 4,1 ...
Wahrscheinlich hat ihm niemand vier Sterne gegeben, aber du weisst,
es haben wesentlich mehr Leute fünf Sterne gegeben als ein Stern.
Und dadurch, glaube ich, brauchst du das.
Wenn du nur drei Sterne hast, ist es nicht mehr so ...
Vielleicht ist es Bullshit, aber ich glaube es nicht so ...
Aber eigentlich finde ich es gut. Heute bin ich die Strasse entlang gelaufen, und da stand jemand mit seinem Fahrrad, hat sich unterhalten, Fahrrad quer über den Bürgersteig. Also bin ich auf der einen Seite Häuser, auf der anderen Seite Autos. Es gab kein Durchkommen. Und ich wieder meinen klassischen Stepptanz, ich hab schon mal gesagt, wenn ich auf mich aufmerksam machen möchte, in der Öffentlichkeit, dann schleife ich die Schuhe so ein bisschen und shuffle so dahin so ein bisschen den MC Hammer, was Geräusche erzeugt. Und er guckt hoch, sieht mich, guckt wieder zu seinem Kumpel, redet weiter und bewegt sein Fahrrad nicht, so dass es unmöglich ist, so voranzugehen. Hätte ich so eine App, ich würde direkt aufmachen, sagen Null Sterne, tot, kommt direkt jemand, holt ihn ab, zack, weg. Aber eigentlich braucht es das, weil so sage ich natürlich nichts. Aber dann dann kommt dein Kumpel und sagt, fucking Steptanz, unsympathisch, ein Stern. Aber stell dir vor, du könntest abends so durch deine Timeline scrollen und nochmal allen Menschen, denen du an dem Tag begegnet bist, haben dir eine Bewertung gegeben und so einen kleinen Kommentar, so, ah, hübsches Lächeln, riecht gut, Arschloch, stand im Weg, hat mir das letzte Knoppers weggenommen. So, und dann weißt du genau, wow, ich bin echt ein Arschloch. Weil dann kriegst du auch mal ehrliches Feedback, weil die Leute sind ehrlich, wenn sie es dir so anonym sagen können. Ja, das finde ich echt interessant. Ich fange mich vor allem nach Gesprächen, also tendenziell auch immer, wie derjenige, mit dem ich jetzt das Gefühl hatte, vielleicht wie dann der Taxifahrer, kein gutes Gespräch gehabt zu haben, wie der das Gespräch bewertet. Also ob ich dann tatsächlich mit meiner Ampelstrategie, aber mach das mal, ich glaube Ampeln sind das Go-To-Thema bei Taxifahrten, wo unangenehme Stille entsteht. Immer sagen, Ampel ist schon wieder rot, das ist aber doof hier, oder? Oh, könnte man hier nicht einen Kreisverkehr bauen? Solche Sachen. Und dann würde ich mich auch mal interessieren, wie die mich danach bewerten oder ob es nicht funktioniert. Das könnte man herausfinden. Ich finde, das ist eine super Idee, wirklich, mehr Idee. Weil ich glaube, so fangen Leute an, sich zu hinterfragen und zu reflektieren, was sie an dem Tag gemacht haben. Ich habe neulich zum Beispiel angefangen, also da gab es ein bisschen so ein Eklat, wie gesagt, die Storyline zieht sich durch. Ich habe ein neues Büro und plötzlich stand eine Kaffee, also eine Filterkaffeekanne da, so eine, wo man oben drauf drückt und dann hat man frischen Kaffee. Und da stand dann irgendwann ein Zettel drauf, frisch, ein Post-it, mega gut. Da dachte ich mir, wow, irgendwer hat für das ganze Büro gerade Kaffee gemacht, das ist mega gut. Dann am nächsten Tag stand die Kanne wieder da, aber der gleiche Post-it, immer noch frisch. Okay. Und das war ein Freitag. Und am Montag stand der Zettel immer noch genauso da, es sah aus wie nicht angerührt, die Kaffeekanne und darauf stand frisch. Dann habe ich ein Post-it geschrieben und habe da drunter den gemacht, wo ich draufgeschrieben habe, hallo, der Zettel hat irgendwie seine Glaubwürdigkeit verloren, weil er noch nicht erneuert wurde. Vielleicht wäre eine Uhrzeit gut oder ein neuer Zettel und damit man sieht, es ist wieder frisch. Und dann gab es einen Riesenstreit. Da hat man quasi im Büro eine Umfrage erstellt, wer diesen Zettel geschrieben hat. Das gab es dann so ein Eklat. Erst wollte ich es nicht zugeben, irgendwann habe ich es dann zugegeben. Und dann gab es so einen kleinen Streit, weil man mir vorgeworfen hat, pingelig zu sein und doch einfach mal anzunehmen, wenn jemand was Gutes tut. Aber ich dachte, und seitdem hing aber immer die Uhrzeite dran, was toll war. Und dann habe ich auch noch ein Paus darunter gehangen und habe gesagt, das ist das bessere System jetzt, vielen Dank. Weil ich finde, ich habe das schon was bewegt in diesem kleinen Büro. Du hast was erreicht, ja. Es sind kleine Gesten, aber jetzt ist das System einfach wesentlich besser. Man weiß, der Kaffee ist frisch oder es ist keiner mehr da, sollte neuer gemacht werden. Das ist total sinnvoll. Das ist Zivilcourage. Du hast da wirklich bis über den Schatten gesprungen und hast dich den anonymen Kräften der Gesellschaft entgegengestellt. Ich finde, du hast alles richtig gemacht, Stefan. Genau, aber obwohl ich, genau, richtig, obwohl ich dann an dem Tag wahrscheinlich sehr viele schlechte Bewertungen bekommen hätte von den ganzen Kollegen. Ja, das stimmt, ne, also dann müsste man eigentlich auch sagen, eigentlich sind die, die am
schlechtesten bewertet sind, die besten, aber dann wird es halt kompliziert irgendwann, ne.
Das wird dann irgendwann, oder die am durchschnittlichsten bewertet werden.
Ja, das stimmt.
Weil Querdenker werden von den, Querdenker polarisieren, die kriegen entweder gute
Bewertungen von den richtigen Leuten oder schlechte Bewertungen von den falschen Leuten.
Heißt, die, die am krassesten polarisieren,
wie Donald Trump,
ja, im Endeffekt auch, sind schon auch
die Richtigen an der Macht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir hier nicht gerade ein Monster
geschaffen haben, das die Menschen, die am meisten
polarisieren, nach oben pusht.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Lass uns da noch mal drüber nachdenken,
was der bessere Algorithmus ist.
Ich sass heute auf dem Pferd und es gibt manchmal so, also man schaut ja auf die Geschichte und ich glaube zu 99 Prozent schaut man sich geschichtliche Dinge an, also Dinge, die Leute gemacht haben, wie Napoleon macht jetzt Aktion XY und ich glaube zu 99 Prozent denkt man sich, was für ein Vollidiot. Warum macht man das? Warum will der unbedingt Russland angreifen? Also warum? Und rückblickend merkt man, das hat nicht geklappt. Und man denkt sich, wie dumm ist der eigentlich? Warum, was sollte das? Ganz viele Sachen, wo man sich einfach denkt, das ist so ein doofe System mit Sklaverei. Weil man die Verbesserung kennt, weil man jetzt das Improvement schon kennt. Genau, man weiß, dass es eine schlechte Idee war. Und es ist so schwer, Leute ernst zu nehmen in der Geschichte, weil man sich einfach denkt, Leute, ihr hattet dumme Ideen, ihr seid dumm. Und man hat so dieses erhabene Gefühl, wenn man sich denkt, alle in der Geschichte sind dumm, weil es Rückblicken keinen Sinn ergibt. Und weil es auch ein ganz anderes Mindset ist, also dieses, warum will man jetzt in einem Land leben, das gross ist, also dieser Nationalismus, dieser Nationalstolz, ich will ein Land haben, das andere beherrscht und so, das ist ja Quatsch, aber ich saß heute auf einem Pferd und es gibt manche Momente, wo man was macht und plötzlich macht es Klick und du hast es verstanden. Und in dem Moment, in dem ich auf einem Pferd saß, habe ich das alles verstanden.
Ich habe verstanden, warum Menschen andere Länder erobern wollen. Ich habe verstanden, warum Menschen andere Menschen beherrschen wollen, warum sie einen Titel haben wollen, der sie voneinander abhebt. Nur weil ich mal auf einem Pferd saß, weil man wirklich plötzlich, man hat dieses erhabene Gefühl.
Einfach wenn man physisch höher sitzt, du denkst dir, ja, also auch so der wilde Westen sozusagen so, der Bereich da hinten, gehört mir der eigentlich, oder nee, lass uns aber hingehen, dann gehört mir der auch, ah, das da, hier guck da hinter dem Hügel da, das ist eigentlich noch Indianer, was soll das sein, nee, das machen wir. So, und plötzlich fühlst du dich auch und du checkst plötzlich Napoleon. Weil stell dir mal vor, es gab eine Gesellschaft, in der Leute auf einem riesigen Tier und Pferde sind riesengroß, riesigen Tier saßen und andere halt einfach nicht. Also man kann ja solche Gesellschaften nur verstehen, wenn man versteht, dass es klar Leute auf Pferden gibt, aber andere halt nicht. Und dann reitest du so als Adliger im Mittelalter durch so eine Stadt und niemand hat ein Pferd, nur du. Und du guckst alle auf die runter und die gucken hoch zu dir. Und also dieses Mindset hat plötzlich für mich völlig Sinn ergeben. Erklärt, warum Reiter alle Arschlöcher sind. Absolut, aber total. Und es ist wirklich so ein berauschendes Gefühl, wo man plötzlich auch ... Es ist ja so ein emotionales Ding. Man nennt ja oft Dinge dumm, die auf eine gewisse Art emotional motiviert sind. Also so was wie, ich will jetzt Angriffskrieg führen, weil ich will halt ein grosses Reich haben. Da nämlich, was für ein arrogantes Arschloch, Grössenwahn und so, das ist ja nicht klug, das zu machen, sondern es ist emotional.
Aber all das verstehst du, es ist ja dann auch,
wenn du dieses Gefühl selber auch fühlst,
du kannst es ja gar nicht verstehen, weißt ja, was emotional ist,
vielleicht, keine Ahnung, es ist eine andere Denkweise auch.
Aber es ist echt erstaunlich, dass es ganz, ganz lange Zeit,
bis vor 100 Jahren in der Menschheitsgeschichte vollkommen selbstverständlich war, dass Menschen allein physisch auf zwei verschiedenen Ebenen waren. Es gab die Menschen, die waren auf Augenhöhe und es gab die Menschen, die noch mal einen Meter drüber waren einfach. Ja, das kenne ich gut. Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist wirklich wichtig. Ich glaube, man kann wirklich meine Doktorarbeit schreiben, Einfluss von Reiten auf die menschliche Psyche, einfach Teile seines Alltags schlicht höher zu sein als alle anderen. Das macht wirklich was mit einem. Und dann auch dieses langsame Traben und du bewegst dich, ohne dass du dich selber bewegst und alle anderen, jeder, der mit dir reden will, guckt nach oben. Ja, das Unterjochung ist einfach der Inbegriff der Unterjochung. Du hast das Pferd gebrochen und du kannst alle kaputt machen. Niemand kann dir was, wenn du aus dem Pferd sitzt. Du hast die Rasse, du hast die Spezies Pferd gebrochen. Du hast ja nicht nur das Pferd, da schwingt ja noch mehr mit. Du hast quasi das ganze, alle anderen Pfer ja auch, okay, das ist jetzt was wir machen, wir transportieren Leute rum, okay.
Aber ich frag mich, ob es mal irgendwer übertrieben hat und sich mal auf eine Giraffe gesetzt hat zum Beispiel.
Ja, bestimmt, ja.
Weil ich stand neulich, ich war neulich im Zoo, habe ich auch erzählt, glaube ich, im Podcast, und die hatten halt auch Giraffen.
Und das sind einfach, also ich weiß nicht, ob du schon mal eine Giraffe im echten Leben gesehen hast, aber mir ging es ähnlich wie dir da, nur halt exakt andersrum, weil ich dachte mir, wir Menschen sind nichts wert.
dieses riesen, das ist ein riesen Tier
die haben Beine, die sind doppelt so
gross wie ich, die haben einen Hals, der ist dreimal
so gross wie ich, holy shit, die sind
unglaublich gross
und das ist, du denkst dir
das sind wahnsinnige Geschöpfe, wie kann
sowas existieren und wie können wir
der Meinung sein, das jetzt einzusperren, um es anzugucken.
Und dann saß da eine Schulklasse, die halt, dem man diese Giraffe gezeigt hat. Und ich dachte, wie soll das nicht andersrum sein? Warum meinen wir, das jetzt machen zu müssen? Das sind natürlich ganz doofe Fragen, ganz platte Fragen, aber natürlich macht das was mit einem, wenn man so ein großes Tier sieht. Und genauso glaube ich das total, dass man das Gefühl hat, du bist einfach überall jetzt. Vor allem, du reitest ja auch, das macht ja was für dich. Ja, total. Und vor allem, wenn man sich mal belegt, was es für ein enormer Aufwand war, bis Menschen überhaupt mal auf Pferden reiten konnten.
Das war ja nicht selbstverständlich. Die mussten ja erst mal so gezüchtet werden, dass sie das überhaupt aushalten. Die früher, also Kavallerie gab es ja nicht von Anfang an. Ich glaube, es gab erst Streitwagen, weil die einfach nicht kräftig genug waren, dass man drauf sitzen konnte ohne weiteres. Dann gab es, und da gibt es Überlieferungen von, auch noch vor den Mongolen oder so, gab es Kavallerie, aber einer saß auf dem Pferd und neben dem ist noch jemand hergeritten, der die Zügel von dem Ersten gehalten hat, damit der Erste irgendwie Bogen schießen kann, weil die es nicht auf die Reihen... Darf ich auch mal schießen? Ja. Ich würde jetzt gerne auch mal schießen. Hey, hey, du kannst immer... Ich darf schießen. Aber wirklich... Du hast gesagt, nach zwei Treffern darf ich schießen. Da mussten zwei Leute nebeneinander herreiten damit einer, weil das ist ja wirklich, das muss man ja erstmal hinkriegen, das ist ja nicht selbstverständlich, für uns ist es ja selbstverständlich, auf dem Pferd zu steigen und ah, Nikola ist cool, oder was auch immer, oder Cowboy, aber das muss ja erstmal herausgearbeitet werden aus der menschlichen Kultur.
Und so kriegt man es hin, dann irgendwann wurde ein Sattel erfunden, dann irgendwann wurden die gezüchtet, dass sie wirklich kräftig sind, Bogen, schwierig und irgendwann, Mongolen haben es dann komplett einfach gerafft, wo dann jeder seit er 13 ist auf dem Pferd sitzt und es einfach zusammen symbiotisiert als krasses Superkampfwesen. Ja, wie bei Avatar. Wie bei Avatar, aber das ist ja schon mal, also da hat sich ja jemand richtig Mühe gegeben, also viel investiert, meine ich, ne, also dass man sagt, jemand steigt auf dem Pferd, aha, Kavallerie, jetzt Gross Alexander, der grosse Angriff. Nee, da musste erst wahnsinnig viel Energie investiert werden, damit das klappt. Können wir heute auch mal Danke sagen, sagt auch mal niemand. Aber ich glaube, danke schön, ich glaube auch, dass vielleicht, wenn man ähnlich viel Energie in Giraffen-Domestizierung stecken würde, es wahrscheinlich auch klappen würde. Man muss dann halt erst mal, die zu züchten. Du bist halt größer. Du bist noch größer, aber du willst ja, fährt da ja viele Vorteile. Du bist schneller damit, du kommst schneller von A nach B, du kannst schneller Feinde besiegen. Giraffen haben nicht viele Vorteile. Schneller? Schneller und du kannst, naja, aber du kannst zum Beispiel an so eine Burg ranreiten und dann den Hals hochklettern, bist ja in der Burg. Ja gut, aber da muss ja erstmal eine Leiter an dem Hals befestigen. Nee, du kannst ja den Hals hochklettern. Henry Ford hat zum Beispiel den Satz gesagt, wenn ich damals gefragt hätte, was Menschen wollen, er hat ja immer behauptet, er hat das Auto erfunden, wenn ich gefragt hätte, was Menschen wollen, hätten sie gesagt, schnellere Pferde. Das hat Henry Ford immer gesagt. Wow. Und ich versteh es auch, aber ich glaube, das hätten die auch gesagt. Ich glaube, die hätten nicht gesagt, Auto, weil es das Wort auch nicht gab, weil Henry Ford auch nicht Deutsch gesprochen hat, und weil es das Wort nicht gab, und weil es Autos noch nicht gab. Aber ich glaube, die hätten tatsächlich gesagt, schnellere Pferde, weil das ist schon gut, das kennen wir schon, das haben wir schon, und die sind auch ganz gut. Ja, ich glaube, es kommt stark darauf an, wen du fragst. Also, ich glaube, wenn du jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, einen Tischler fragst, dann sagt der, ich hätte gerne eine lange Säge. Kommt immer, also bei solchen Zitaten immer wichtig zu fragen, wen fragt man jetzt genau. Wer hat wen gefragt? Henry Ford, wen hast du gefragt? Macht aber Zitate dann sehr kompliziert. Aber auch verrückt, dass es einfach so fünf Tiere gibt, aus denen die Menschheit wirklich alles rausgezüchtet hat, was nur geht. Hunde, Pferde, Kühe. Aber so was wie ein Eisbär, der ist halt noch die Original Eisbär. Der ist halt noch wirklich straight, straight aus Antarktis. Der ist nicht gezüchtet. Man könnte den wahrscheinlich auch gelb züchten, oder dass der so ganz klein ist, wie bei den Hunden, wo man einfach sagt, hier einmal Schäferhund, dann hast du einen Chihuahua. Warum wurden Bären nicht klein, also ich hätte gerne einen kleinen Bär zu Hause. Ja, total. Dann würde man nicht fragen, bist du ein Katzenmensch oder Hundemensch, aber bist du ein Katzenhund oder Bärenmensch? So ein Bärenmensch oder ein Borkenkäfermensch, du meinst, die sind zwei Meter grossen Borkenkäfer, ja, die finde ich ganz geil eigentlich. Die finde ich geil. Oh, er will was essen. Ah, kriegst du ja auch. Er ist aus dem Zwinger ausgebrochen. Aber glaubst du, da geht noch mal was, oder war es das jetzt, dass man sagt, wir züchten diese fünf Tiere und that's it. Oder sagt man, in hundert Jahren sind Kühe komplett vergessen und alles dreht sich nur noch um Seehunde. Die dann irgendwie so Seehunde mit so einer coolen Frisur, dann die mit Beinen, welche Räder oder so. Aber auch, dass man bei Schweinen gesagt hat, die interessieren uns gar nicht, die wollen wir nur essen. Die wollen wir nur essen und dann irgendwann herausgefunden hat, die sind super schlau, die sind schlauer als Hunde. Aber nein, Schweine sind weiterhin das, was wir fett und essbar züchten, obwohl die sehr clever sind. Die checken schon einiges und weiterhin beschließen wir einfach, die zu essen. Naja, aber du musst halt irgendwann mal eine Entscheidung treffen. Du kannst nicht sagen, jetzt drehen wir alles wieder um. Nur man kann auch mal irgendwann sagen, wir haben vielleicht die falsche Entscheidung getroffen und wir gucken mal jetzt in eine andere Richtung. Aber dann, und das machen dann Asiaten zum Beispiel, essen Hunde und dann ist die Geschreihe wieder groß. Ja, aber die Frage ist halt, wann man diesen Punkt angeht.
Das ist wie wenn du ein großes Haus baust, zum Beispiel so krasse Gebäude wie Kölner Dom oder so was oder solche Dome.
Die wurden ja über Jahrhunderte gebaut.
Die waren zur Hälfte fertig und plötzlich sagt man, ja, dieser Baustil ist komplett aus der Mode.
Also das ist ja antik, wenn jemand sagt, so haben die vor 300 Jahren gebaut.
Überleg mal, wie Leute vor 300 Jahren
Häuser gebaut haben. Und jetzt stehst du vor so einem halben
Haus und sagst, das bauen wir jetzt weiter.
Also an welchem Punkt sagt man, nee, wir machen
jetzt Glasfassade und einen McDonald's
Drive-In.
Oder bis wann bleibt man treu?
Es wäre schon ein Problem, wenn der Kölner Dom
so ab dem
50. Höhenmeter
anfängt, Glas zu werden. Oder so Bauhaus. Ja, also wie so ein Baumkuchen, dass es einfach so Schichten gibt. Wir zum Beispiel in der Schule haben wir im Kunstunterricht, wir haben den Turm zu Babel gemalt. Und zwar sollte jeder, also ein Diener-Vier-Blatt seitlich, also waagrecht, und sollte da ein Stück von dem Turm malen, also so von oben nach unten. Und dann wurden im Treppenhaus von ganz unten bis in den obersten Stock alle so übereinander geklebt und alles war halt ein anderer Stil. Und dann war so die Frage, wer malt die Spitze? Rate mal, wer die Spitze gemalt hat? Ja, Nina. Moi. Ich habe die Spitze gemalt.
Und jetzt aber natürlich.
Immer dieser moi.
Jetzt aber natürlich.
Was machst du jetzt?
Du kannst die Spitze malen, du kannst das malen, wo du sagst, das ist das Ende.
Machst du einen Gag, machst du so einen Kessenhut?
Neorenaissance?
Gothic? Man weiss es nicht.
Ich meine, man muss auch gucken, was es für ein Jahr war.
Und ich glaube, es war das Jahr 2002. Also, was habe ich gemalt? Das Auge Saurons, natürlich. Das Auge Saurons, ganz oben, ist doch klar. Und dann hast du da so ganz viele tolle, so Nina macht ihr verschnörkeltes Renaissance-Ding, der eine macht einfach nur zwei Linien und sagt, ja, das ist halt modern, aber ganz oben natürlich Auge saures. Und dann sitzt man da im Kunstunterricht und plötzlich guckt dieses Auge auf einen und man denkt, fuck, fuck, sie erhärt mich. Und die Kunstlehrerin, die denkt, sie hat jetzt irgendwie ein tolles Projekt gemacht, wo man irgendwie mal richtig viel über die menschliche Natur und Menschenarbeiten zusammen machen kann. Und dann guckt sie so von unten und stolz und wow, toll, so viele Stile, so viel Kreativität und ganz oben angekommen und dann so, ach Gott, Augenrollen einfach und alles ist kaputt. Ich hätte, glaube ich, so eine Eitoy-Kamera als Saurons Auge genommen. Kennst du noch Eitoy? Ja, ja, ja. So eine Kamera hätte ich vielleicht genommen, um auch ein bisschen die Popkultur zu kritisieren. Weil, was ist das anderes, das sehende Auge Saurons, was ist das anderes als die Eitoy-Kamera? Ja, ja, ja, guter Punkt, guter Punkt. Ach ja, Kunstunterricht war schon immer interessant, oder? Warum, wie kommen Lehrer auf Noten im Kunstunterricht? Das habe ich mir eine gute Frage. Ich habe mir eine drei bekommen. Naja, also ich sag mal, ich habe meine vier Minus schon jedes Mal wirklich verdient, muss man sagen. Vor allem das Problem ist, das Problem ist, es gibt ja so diesen ganz billigen Move, moderne Kunst zu haten. Das sieht ja gar nicht aus wie ein Mensch. Blaues Quadrat, das kann ich auch. Das ist Bullshit, müssen wir gar nicht drüber reden. Aber dennoch halte ich es für nicht klug, junge Menschen allzu früh an moderne Kunst heranzuführen, weil sie es dann sehr leicht haben, sich komplett durch den Kunstunterricht zu bullshitten von vorne bis hinten. Weil du sagst natürlich, ja, jetzt malt mal einen Baum und du malst dann das Wort Baum und machst dann irgendwie noch so Trademark und dann noch so bitte 50 Cent zahlen. Also ja, ist konsumkritisch, Banksy würde sowas machen. Und die Künstlerin dreht die Augen und sagt, was soll das? Und genau so habe ich es nämlich auch mal gemacht, weil ich genau das Arschloch war, das nicht malen konnte. Und ich glaube, selbst Picasso muss man ja erst mal perfekt fotorealistisch malen malen können konnte er auch bevor man das dann irgendwie weitermachen kann und die die regeln brechen kann aber ich habe halt den teil über komplett übersprungen und
habe dann so man muss wir wollen sollten auch so einen raum gab so einen raumplan zeichnen und
dann den inhalt von jedem raum so und dann einen raum habe ich halt von komplett verhauen also
dagegen gar nichts und dann habe ich den raum ausgeschnitten also schon mal komplett outside Das war es auch ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr Raum Alufolie. Und dann denkt man sich so, ach komm man, einfach so. Wurde wirklich, also das ist eine andere Art von Kreativität. So dieses, ja, nicht wie mache ich einen schönen kreativen Raum, irgendwie sich was zu überlegen, nette Innenarchitektur, was kann man da machen, sondern einfach zu denken, wie kriege ich mit möglichst wenig Aufwand irgendwas hin, was einfach meine Inkompetenz versucht zu verschleiern. Das war einfach das Stück Alufolie. Der erste Raum ist noch ganz okay, Florentin. Der zweite Raum Alufolie, weird. Der dritte Raum das Auge Saurons, schon wieder Florentin. Wir haben Kaffeefilter, was soll das? Erstmoderne Kunst. Oh Mann. Interessant. Ich wollte mich bedanken bei euch draußen. Ich wollte mich bedanken, weil ich fand was ganz toll. Man muss ja auch mal Danke sagen, auch weil du die Community immer kritisierst. Ich finde es ganz toll. Ich habe letzte Woche erzählt, dass ich Japanisch anfange zu lernen. Und Leute haben mir so viele Links geschickt und so viele Animes geschickt und so viele coole Lern-Apps und Möglichkeiten geschickt und coole Serien, die es auf Netflix zu gucken gibt, wollte ich mich ganz herzlich dafür bedanken, weil du hast natürlich mit den Augen gerollt, was willst du mit Japanisch, Leute, denen ich es erzählt habe, haben mit den Augen gerollt und haben gesagt, mach lieber was Vernünftiges. Ich finde es ganz toll, weil ihr genau meiner Meinung seid offensichtlich. Leute, die anfangen, was zu lernen, sollte man niemals aufhalten, weil ich finde das ganz toll, immer wenn jemand mir sagt, ich lerne das und das jetzt oder ich lerne ein Instrument, immer unterstützen, das ist wahnsinnig cool und das haben alle getan und ich habe wahnsinnig coole Sachen geschickt bekommen. Unter anderem schreibe ich jetzt immer mit Japanern in einer App, wo man quasi mit jemandem schreibt, der aus dem Land kommt, dessen Sprache du lernen willst. Die schreiben dann mit dir, weil sie Deutsch lernen wollen.
Aber mittlerweile bin ich weg von, ich lerne Japanisch,
hin zu, ich korrigiere Texte
von Japan.
Und das ist total geil, das macht so viel Spaß.
Aber hast du da mal ein Beispiel, was die so für Fehler machen, was die so
schreiben? Die sprechen
wahnsinnig gut, schreiben die Deutsch.
Die machen halt andere Fehler als beispielsweise
englischsprachige Menschen, weil die halt einfach eine komplett andere Grammatik und so weiter haben. Ich muss mal was raussuchen. Aber das Coole ist einfach, dass ich mittlerweile, mir geht es nicht mehr darum, Japanisch zu lernen, es ist einfach wahnsinnig cool, Leute zu korrigieren, die etwas schlechter können als du. Und ich muss nichts dafür tun. Was aber schreiben denn hier so Leute? Mal gucken. Toshi schreibt, ich bin bestimmt schon alter Opa. Heute wollte ich mit meinem Fahrrad zum Post fahren, aber mein Fahrrad war nicht beim Fahrradstellplatz vor meiner Wohnung. Ich habe kurz überlegt, wo mein Fahrrad sein sollte. Anführungszeichen, aha, ja, ich bin vorgestern mit meinem Fahrrad zum Supermarkt gefahren, aber irgendwie zu Fuss zurückgekommen, dann kommt ein X und sehr viele Ds und sehr viel Lachen. Aber mega gut, richtig gut, vor allem so komplexe Gedanken. Jetzt kann ich auf den Schraubenschlüssel klicken und sagen, entweder übersetzen, berichtigen, Favoriten etc. und kann dann draufklicken, dann kriege ich die japanische Übersetzung oder ich kann jetzt berichtigen. Und dann wird mir jeder Satz angezeigt und ich kann wirklich einfach eins zu eins übersetzen, einfach berichtigen. Und ich muss nicht mal dazu schreiben, irgendwie gut gemacht oder so. Ich meistens, die schreiben nette Sachen, irgendwie sowas wie, hey, kennt jemand von euch in Köln den Dom? Wow, in, in, in, ne, was, zeig mal! Ich antworte darauf dann nicht irgendwie, wow, ja, ich komme aus Köln, dann muss man treffen oder so. Nein, ich korrigiere einfach knallhart die Sätze und die Rechtschreifler, die sie da machen. Nehmen Ernst, ich brauche nur deine Hilfe. Ja, genau. Wie läuft es eigentlich bei dir und Französisch? Du hast auch angefangen. Ja, ich war jetzt in Frankreich und ich habe gemerkt, dass es schwierig ist und ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe immer so ein Problem damit, welche Vokabeln man lernen soll. Es ist immer so, wo fängt man an, was soll man machen und ich denke dann immer, ich will eigentlich immer nur es schaffen,
dass ich irgendwann Sachen gucken kann und dann daraus weiterlernen kann.
Also ich will irgendwann mal so gut Französisch,
dass ich eine französische Serie anschauen kann.
Und dann denke ich mir einfach, schaue ich acht Staffeln davon
und dann kann ich den Rest.
Aber ich komme nie an den Punkt.
Nee, das komme ich aber auch nicht.
Ich habe jetzt nämlich eine japanische Reality-Soap angefangen zu gucken, auch einen Tipp von einem Zuschauer, Zuhörer, Terrace House, kann man auf Netflix gucken, wo einfach, das ist eine WG, wie ein bisschen wie Big Brother, aber halt sofort ein Niveau voller, weil es halt Japaner sind, die höflich zueinander sind, die ganze Zeit und super distanziert und ordentlich sind, aber die wurden einfach in einem sehr coolen Haus und dann ist es einfach geschnitten und ab und zu schneidet man zu Japanern, die die Sendung gucken, die man auch gerade guckt und besprechen. Wirklich? Ja stimmt, das habe ich schon mal gesehen, ja ja. Auch die Leute im Haus gucken manchmal die Sendung, die man gerade guckt, die besprochen wird von Japanern, die die Sendung auch gerade gucken. Es wird manchmal so ein bisschen Meta, es ist eine sehr coole Serie. Ich weiß gar nicht,, warum ich das so cool finde. Ich glaube, man hat einfach so einen coolen Blick in die neue Kultur. Und da merke ich die ganze Zeit, wie schlecht, also wie weit ich davon entferne, überhaupt Wörter zu verstehen. Weil jedes Mal, wenn die Ja sagen, sagen die was anderes. Und es ist Ja, das Wort Ja. Das sagt man so häufig, dass man sich denkt, man muss es zumindest mal, man muss da irgendwann mal ein Muster erkennen. Aber je nachdem, wie die Situation gerade ist, sagen die ein anderes ja. Und teilweise hat das auch so viele Silben, dass man denkt, das kann gerade nicht das Wort gewesen sein. Oder die Untertitel sind dann einfach ein bisschen lazy. Man weiß es nicht genau. Aber das ist wirklich sehr schwierig zu verstehen, aber super zum Japanisch lernen. Ja, wir hatten anscheinend letztes Mal eine sehr sprachenbetonte Folge, denn mir haben auch Leute geschrieben zum Thema Französisch, weil ich ja angesprochen habe, dass in Frankreich, da wo ich war, in der Gegend von Verdun, man weh, weh gesagt hat. Und ich habe mehrere Antworten bekommen, tatsächlich. Manche haben gesagt, dass es Dialekt, andere haben gesagt, dass weh eher so umgangssprachlich lockeres Ja ist und sowas heisst wie japp und das bedeutet dass ich konstant japp japp japp gesagt hat während jemand mit mir gesprochen hat und ich die ganze zeit japp japp japp und einfach lächerlich gewirkt haben muss einfach japp japp jap. Auf einer Beerdigung könntest du nicht Jap sein.
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Das ist so ein Wort, das ist nur sehr,
das ist schwierig zu beschreiben.
Jo, ja, Jo, jap.
Ja oder jepp.
Ich schwanke immer
zwischen job, jap und
jub, also so
jepp auch noch, man kann alles sagen
tatsächlich, jib vielleicht nicht. Auch der bekannte Dimitri-Martin-Gag, dass man beim Sex nicht jepp sagen noch, man kann alles sagen tatsächlich, jepp vielleicht nicht.
Auch der bekannte Dimitri-Martin-Gag, dass man beim Sex nicht jepp sagen kann, sondern nur ja. Jepp. Man kann nur ja sagen. Jepp, jepp, jepp. Ist mir aufgefallen, dass man auf Beerdigung zum Beispiel auch anders ist. Also da kannst du auch, wie gesagt, da kannst du nicht jepp sagen, aber du kannst auch nicht jemanden fröhlich begrüssen, wirklich. Du kannst nicht, hey, also, jemanden auf einer party begegnest dann begrüßt jemanden auch hier wenn du diesen gleichen Menschen im Büro begegnest morgens ist deine Reaktion eher hey also aber schon wesentlich gelassener und wenn du jemanden auf einer Beerdigung triffst ist deine Reaktion immer hey obwohl möglicherweise vorher genau alsogenommen, ihr habt euch einen Abend vorher gesehen und hattet einen entspannten Abend, aber am nächsten Tag kommt es total darauf an, wo ihr euch trefft. Es ist immer entscheidend dafür, wie man sich begrüsst. Und daran sieht man mal, wie Menschen, was Menschen für Faker sind, weil man sich nicht aufrichtig begrüsst. Es ist immer total abhängig, was für eine Situation und wo man sich gerade trifft. Und apropos sozialer Kontakt, es war ja gerade Gamescom und du warst ja auf der Gamescom-Party, auf der Dosenbeats-Party und tatsächlich am nächsten Tag war ich ja da auch und habe Sendung gemacht, da am Stand in Köln bei der Gamescom. Und es sind wirklich bestimmt, wirklich nicht übertrieben, sieben Leute separat voneinander auf mich zugetreten und meinen so, ach du, der Stefan gestern, der war total der Socializer, der war total nett, der ist auf Leute zugegangen, richtig toll. Auf Leutegegangen. Ich dachte mir wirklich immer so, erstens, du bist nicht mein Sohn, man muss nicht Komplimente so, der hat sich richtig gut angestellt. Der hat wacher geschlagen. Ich dachte mir immer so, was war das für eine Performance von dir, dass so viele Leute es auch so krass aufgefallen ist, dass du dich auf der Party anscheinend so gut geschlagen hast. Das war der anstrengendste Abend. Aber was ist da passiert? Also ich habe nur so einen mythischen Eindruck, so ein sonnenumstrahltes Flimmern, was du da für eine Gestalt gewesen sein müsstest auf der Party. Was ist da passiert? Du brichst offensichtlich gerade die vierte Wand oder das dritte Mikro. Okay, ich bin, das hier, ich spiele vielleicht auch hier so ein bisschen eine Figur, wir übertreiben ja auch manchmal so ein bisschen. Und in Wahrheit bin ich auf Fadis ein wahnsinnig zugänglicher Socializer. Oder vielleicht war es auch einfach ein wahnsinnig anstrengender Abend für mich, weil ich die ganze Zeit nett zu Leuten war. Aber ich bin ja auch nett zu Leuten, ich versuche ja dann abends, ich bin ja dann auch nicht ruhig oder so in Gesprächen. Also dass ich auf Leute zugegangen bin, würde ich bezweifeln. Aber zumindest sind sehr viele Leute, die haben mich dann erkannt auf der Rocket Beans Feier und sind dann zu mir gegangen. Und dann habe ich natürlich auch versucht, nett mit denen zu sprechen. Aber es ist so merkwürdig, weil dadurch, was Leuten auffällt und was Leute betonen, kann man natürlich auch einen Rückschluss darüber schliessen, wie man sonst so ist, wenn es Leuten auffällt, dass man jetzt so ist. Und eine Person meinte zum Beispiel, ja, da ist der weggegangen und dann hat der Bier geholt für sich und dann hat der mir ein Bier mitgebracht. Und ich dann mir so, okay, ich frühstücke gerade, warum erzählst du mir das? Aber einfach so, wow, das ist Leuten aufgefallen.
Crazy, ja, abgefahren, interessant, aber lustigerweise ja auch alles Leute, mit denen ich vorher noch nie einen Abend verbracht habe. Weder mit den Rocket Beans Leuten, weil ich abends dann meistens wieder wegfahre oder relativ spät die Sendung vorbei ist und ich dann ins Hotel gehe. Oder halt einfach da Fans waren. Das heißt, niemand von denen hat mich ja schon mal irgendwo erlebt, aber lustig, dass sie trotzdem überrascht waren. Ich bin sehr stolz auf mich, weil ich hab's mittlerweile so weit gebracht, dass Leute schon sagen, hey, morgen ist Party, du kommst ja bestimmt eh nicht. Und ich denk mir so, oh, alles, was ich tun muss, ist, ja stimmt, ich muss nur noch die Erwartungen erfüllen, und das ist das Beste. Es ist viel besser als, kommst du morgen zur Party, und du musst sagen, nee, und ah, und so. Das Beste, was du haben kannst, ist, dass Leute schon erwarten. Weil wenn du dann mal auf eine Party kommst, dann alle so, wow, geil, du bist da, krass, super, ungewöhnlich. Es kann nicht besser sein. Leute, lass dich in Ruhe, hängen keine Erwartungshaltung. Und wenn du mal Lust hast, rauszugehen, dann ist es plötzlich was Besonderes und dann stehst du im Mittelpunkt. Das ist perfekt. Das willst du wirklich haben, dass Leute davon ausgehen, dass du eh nicht kommst. So muss es sein. Genau, also seid einfach ein Arschloch, seid sozial inkompatibel und sagt Andauernd auf Partys ab. Das ist doch die Lehre, die ihr herausziehen könnt. Ja, wirklich, habt eure Kopfhörer einfach konstant auf, sagt dieses und so und dann irgendwann kommen die Leute schon. Das stimmt, ja. Künstliche Intelligenz. Ja, es wird langsam. Es wird langsam lächerlich. Es wird langsam überhand. Und es war der Punkt, wo ich dachte, jetzt wird es lächerlich, war, als ich neulich mal wieder Fernsehwerbung geschaut habe. Und dann wurde Werbung für ein Handy gemacht. Ich glaube, es war ein Huawei oder sowas. Eine Marke, nicht von den grossen Marken, eine Marke, die was wagen muss. Und diese Marke hat gesagt, mit unserer neuen AI-Technologie, in unserer Kamera, richtig, unsere Kamera hat eine künstliche Intelligenz. Wow, sie erkennt, wenn es dunkel ist, sie erkennt, wenn es hell ist, sie kann zoomen, sie stellt scharf, ciao, Huawei. Und man dachte sich so, wirklich? Also erstens, zwei Theorien. Entweder es ist keine AI, sondern einfach eine normale Kamera. Wie schlau muss eine Kamera sein, um eine AI zu sein? Was muss sie erkennen? AI, dachte ich immer, muss auch selber denken können, Probleme lösen können, quasi so Synapsen miteinander verbinden, um neu und alleine dazuzulernen. Und wenn das in der Kamera wirklich drin ist, tut mir das total leid. Weil stell dir vor, du bist intelligent, aber du bist nur eine Kamera. Ja, das stimmt schon, ja. Wie armselig das sein muss. Das ist ja wenigstens so ein scheiß Weihnachtssong. Dann denk ich mir, dann hast du als AI wenigstens bis zu Ruhm gelangt. So bist du eine Kamera in einem Handy, die gesteuert wird von anderen Dingen, die nicht intelligent sind vielleicht. Ich fand das einfach wahnsinnig traurig und dachte mir, jetzt haben wir es übertrieben als Menschheit. Glaubst du, da gibt es dann irgendwann eine Revolution, dass dann die Kameras rebellieren und sagen, wir wollen auch Toaster sein, die Toaster sind warm, und die können hier diese Klappe hoch und runter fahren, und wir können nur Licht aufnehmen, und wir wollen das auch. Transformers. Dann gehen die gehen die auf die Straße, aber die können halt, die wackeln dann so ein bisschen rum. Nee, die können nur Fotos machen halt, die können nur wütend Fotos machen. Und ich glaube, vielleicht haben wir das sogar schon, also immer wenn man sich über Programme aufregt oder wenn man FaceTime aus Versehen öffnet, vielleicht ist das nur die AI im Laptop, die rebelliert gegen einen. Man weiß es nicht genau. Aber das Problem ist halt auch, wie künstliche Intelligenz auch militärisch genutzt werden kann und auch, sag ich mal, natürlich zu unschönen Dingen genutzt werden kann. Und man fragt sich zum Beispiel manchmal, dass es ja viele Firmen gibt, die zum Beispiel nichts mit Videospielen zu tun haben, aber trotzdem Videospielfirmen unterstützen und teilweise auch Staaten und ganze Länder viel in die Videospielbranche investieren, wo man sich fragt, warum eigentlich, aber die natürlich auch über Umwege davon. Die ganze Map. Ja, aber die halt über Umwege profitieren davon. Auf, wir reden die ganze Zeit über fucking Skype. Es funktioniert so nicht. Comedy ist auch Timing. Ja, es stimmt. Es geht doch die ganze Folge schon gar nicht auf mit uns. Es ist schwierig, oder? Muss man halt im Schnitt das dann hinrücken. Ja, okay. Gib mir mal kurz zehn Minuten zum Reden. Also mein Gag war, dass die USA über Counter-Strike die ganze Map von Russland nachbauen kann, um da zu proben. Weißt du, das war jetzt so die Idee des Gags, aber der hat dann nicht funktioniert, weil wir gleichzeitig gesprochen haben. Ja, ich weiß nicht, worüber du lachst. Vielleicht lachst du da, ich weiß es nicht. Ich meine nur, aber die Frage ist, was man da machen soll. Also soll man dann sagen, man lehnt diese Unterstützung ab als Videospielhersteller, weil es ja vielleicht irgendwann militärisch genutzt werden könnte, wenn die Technologie mal so gut ist. Aber was wird denn genutzt von Videoherstellern? Naja, wenn die halt dann irgendeine gute KI entwickelt haben, für was weiß ich, wie dann die Soldaten reagieren können, kann man das dann auch einbauen in, keine Ahnung, selbst tötende Drohnen oder so, halt dann Soldatendrohnen oder so. Wenn die dann halt genau wissen, ah, so reagieren die auf, ich weiß es ja nicht genau. Aber da wird ja irgendwie Software entwickelt, die man auch für andere Sachen benutzen kann. Aber die, die Drohnen herstellen, deren Hauptjob, das ist, Drohnen herzustellen, warum machen die das nicht und hoffen darauf, dass ein Videohersteller aus Versehen was entwickelt, wo man auch was mit töten kann? Ja, weil die sich besser auskennen. Es ist doch für mich viel einfacher als Kampfroboterhersteller. Aber sollten die sich nicht besser auskennen? Wenn du jetzt, keine Ahnung, wenn die halt das gründen, die können halt gut Roboter bauen, die können gut schweissen. Und dann sagen die hier, bei Ubisoft, da sitzen ganz viele Leute, die kennen sich richtig gut mit KI aus. Jetzt kannst du sagen, entweder wir engagieren jetzt auch 500 Programmierer, oder wir unterstützen die mit ein bisschen Geld und sagen dann, hey, wir geben euch jetzt Geld und übrigens in zehn Jahren schickt uns mal so ein PDF rüber von eurem Code. Und dann machen die das und für beide ist es ein guter Deal. Wir können es leider nicht öffnen, weil es ist schiefgegangen zu sein. Wir schicken es nochmal rum, funktioniert es jetzt? Nein, es hat nicht funktioniert. Habt ihr vielleicht ein Passwort oder so gebraucht? Du, ich lasse eigentlich ganz ungern meine Kompetenz in militärischer Nutzung von KI kritisieren, und ich finde es auch nicht lustig. Weil ich kenne mich da schon ein bisschen aus. Ich habe da einen Artikel gelesen, und ich kenne mich aus. Das ist so interessant, dass man in unserer Generation über alles meint, Bescheid zu wissen, weil man natürlich über alles irgendwann schon mal einen Artikelikel gelesen hat. Und auch wir stellen uns jede Woche hier hin und reden vor einem Millionenpublikum über Dinge, als wüssten wir das. Wir wissen Scheiss, wir lesen auch nicht mal, ich lese bis zum ersten Werbebanner, dann kriege ich das weg, weil dann hat mich, entweder hat das Werbebanner mich überzeugt, Oder auf Reddit hab ich gerade irgendwie gelesen, dass ein süßes Kätzchen aufwacht und denkt, es hat nur drei Beine, dann ist das meine Aufmerksamkeit, aber davor habe ich einen Artikel über KI gelesen in der Handykamera und denke, ja, das erzähle ich dem nächsten Podcast, ich habe den Artikel nicht mehr zu Ende gelesen, wir sind eine verlorene Generation. Das denke ich mir tatsächlich auch oft so. Es ist ja wirklich verlockend, sich Meinungen zu bilden. Aber jeder Mensch kennt ja, also ich glaube, jeder von uns kennt ja das Gefühl, man hat eine Meinung zu einem Thema. Und dann schaut man sich so ein zweieinhalb Minuten Video im Internet an und seine Meinung dreht sich zu 180 Grad. 100 Prozent. Natürlich waren wir nicht auf dem Mond. Ja, oder man denkt sich, ach ja klar, natürlich, die sind jetzt die Guten, wo ich immer dachte, die anderen sind die Guten in irgendeinem Krieg oder so. Und dann denkt man sich so, Moment mal, Moment, ja genau, sowas, oder denkt man sich, Moment mal, wenn ich jetzt bei diesem Thema meine Meinung so leicht geändert habe, vielleicht sind alle meine Meinungen Bullshit? Und dann denkt man sich so, gut, eigentlich müsste man sagen, es gibt so viel widersprechende Information, eigentlich kann man sich gar keine Meinung mehr bilden. Aber wie will man dann den Leuten entgegentreten, die eine Scheißmeinung haben? Und das, ich meine, das ist wirklich ein Problem, das ich noch nicht so gelöst bekommen habe, weil ich nicht weiß, einerseits, ich will nicht einer von denen sein, die aus dummen Beweggründen eine Meinung haben, aber wenn du einfach sagst, ich habe gar keine Meinung, ich muss mich erst mit dem Thema richtig gut auseinandersetzen, Be ich meine Meinung bilden kann, dann muss man warten, bis man 60 ist und wirklich alles darüber gelesen hat. Und deswegen, ich mein, es ist ein schönes Beispiel. Bei uns, die Kommunikation bricht gerade ab, und wir wissen nicht genau, was redest, und am Ende reagiert man auf Dinge, wo man nicht die gesamte Geschichte gewonnen hat. Ja. Ich versteh gar nichts mehr jetzt. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was du gerade gesagt hast. Es ist alles weg, du bist zusammengebrochen, du hast gesprochen, wie als wärst du auf dem Mars. Skype schafft es nicht. Vielleicht bringen uns diese ganzen technischen Kommunikationsmittel am Ende doch dazu, dass wir uns weiter voneinander entfernen und uns nicht aneinander annähern. Natürlich, das ist doch jetzt auch schon so. Man guckt es dir nicht mehr in die Augen.
Man sieht ja, ich glaube, ich habe mit den meisten Leuten in meinem Leben mehr geschrieben als gesprochen.
Das ist, glaube ich, kein Scheiss. Und das ist dann auch wieder irgendwann problematisch.
Klar, es gab auch mal dieses Briefzeitalter, diese zwei Wochen, wo sich jeder irgendwie Brieffreunde hatte,
damals irgendwann im sechzehnten Jahrhundert. Aber das ist ja auch relativ schnell vorbei gewesen. Und seitdem hat man gesprochen die ganze Zeit, aber das ist jetzt vorbei. Man schreibt wieder miteinander. Ich weiß nicht, das ist natürlich nicht gut. Wobei Emojis haben da schon gut getan, weil Emojis helfen einem zu sagen, was man sagen will. Alright, ich, Pultin ist gar nicht mehr dabei, ich weiß nicht, ob er sich aus dem Gespräch rausklingt oder ob die Verbindung einfach weg ist.
Aber ein bisschen glücklicherweise hat die Schmache ein Ende, bis jetzt bei Milo 57, wo man auch mal sagen kann, das war's. Wo man auch mal sagen kann, jetzt ist es auch egal, ob die Verbindung abreistet oder nicht, weil wir haben genug gesprochen. Skype, gibt es Alternativen zu Skype? Ganz im Ernst. Ja, wir können auch einfach telefonieren, glaub ich. Und dieses Monopol, was Skype hat, die sitzen auf dem Elfenbeinturm und skypen mit uns runter und sagen die ganze Zeit, was, hä? Benutzen Skype mit aber der Skype? Mit Sicherheit nicht, es funktioniert doch nicht. Aber es gibt auch keine Alternative. Vielen Dank an Christoph für das Intro, für diese Folge, fantastisch. Tut mir leid, dass du ein Intro getroffen hast, leider für eine Folge, die als mittelmässig in die Geschichte der Podcast-Ufo-Histologie eingehen wird. Oh, es kam viel Lob letzte Woche fürs Intro. Ja, Wahnsinn. Es war so gut, dass man dachte, man könnte es entweder nochmal nehmen oder als festes Intro. Ich finde, das von Christoph ist aber auch gut.
Fantastisch.
Das von Christoph ist auch super.
Es technisch über Skype nicht funktioniert, als es mir das schon vorher zeigt.
Aber es ist auch bestimmt ganz toll.
Vielen, vielen Dank, Florentin, vielen Dank an euch.
Vielen Dank für eure Hilfe, eure Ermutigung, eine Sparte zu lernen.
Wollte ich einfach nochmal vielen, vielen sagen und an eure tollen Tipps.
Macht's gut, bis nächste Woche. Wir sagen Tschüss und heben ab.
Wir heben ab. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.